Welcome back.
I just want to do a couple more
of these problems, just so you,
I guess, see a few couple more
problems and get some practice.
So let's start with
another problem.
As always, let me
draw my triangle.
I always like to draw
it a little different
to confuse you.
Let's say that this angle
up here is 0.36 radians.
An angle is 0.36 radians, and
then this side right here, this
top side-- let me do it in a
different color-- this top side
in pink is square root of
73 units long or whatever.
It could be inches or
feet or whatever.
But it's square root
of 73 units long.
So my question is, what is this
side here, this green side?
Well, how did we do this
type of problem last time?
We should figure out what
sides we're dealing with.
Are we dealing with the
adjacent and the opposite, the
adjacent and the hypotenuse,
the opposite and the
hypotenuse, and then we'll know
which trig functions we
should be dealing with.
So we know this side, this pink
side-- and this pink side, it
should be almost second
nature by now, is the
hypotenuse, right?
It's the longest side, and it's
opposite the right angle.
So we know the hypotenuse,
and what are we solving for?
Well, this is the angle we
know, so we're solving
for the opposite side.
So we're solving for the
opposite side, and we know the
hypotenuse, so what trig
function will we probably use?
Let's write out our mnemonic.
SOH CAH TOA.
So what did I say before?
We're solving for the opposite
sign, and we know the
hypotenuse, so we are going to
use the opposite and
the hypotenuse.
So which of these is that?
The opposite and the
hypotenuse, the o
and the h, right?
It's SOH, right?
And SOH says that sine is
equal to the opposite
over the hypotenuse.
Sine of an angle-- in this
case, it's this angle-- sine of
0.36 radians-- remember, this
is radians we're dealing with,
not degrees-- is equal
to the opposite side.
And the opposite side is this
green side right here, so I'll
just write opposite instead of
writing o because o would look
like a 0-- is equal to the
opposite side over the
hypotenuse, right?
This is just sine is equal to
opposite over hypotenuse.
Well, what's the
hypotenuse length?
Well, it's the
square root of 73.
These are p's, by the way.
I know they don't look
like p's, but opposite.
So the opposite side-- we're
just multiplying both sides by
the square root of 73-- is
equal to the square root of 73
times the sine of 0.36 radians.
Now, once again, I don't know
what the sign of 0.36 radians
is in my head, but I'll
tell you the answer.
The sine of 0.36 radians is
equal to-- I'm just rewriting
this-- the sine of 0.36
radians, if you looked it up on
a table or if you used your
calculator in radian mode, is 3
square roots of 73 over 73.
And, of course, your calculator
is going to give you
something-- it'll give
you some decimal number.
I won't write it this way.
So just remember, this is this.
And I just looked that up.
There's no magic there.
And the square root-- or you
could use a calculator.
On the Khan Academy, when you
do problems, it'll actually
tell you what it is, so you
don't have to use a calculator.
So now we just simplify.
Square root of 73 times square
root of 73 is 73 over 73 is
equal to 1, so these
all cancel out.
And we get the answer of 3.
So this side right here is 3.
And just out of curiosity, if
you wanted to solve for this
side, there's two ways
we could do it, right?
We could use the Pythagorean
theorem, because, you know, a
squared plus b squared is
equal to c squared, or we
could use trigonometry.
I'll let you guess
what trig function--
actually, let's do that.
Let's figure out that side
using trigonometry, and then
let's figure out that side
using the Pythagorean theorem,
just to show that everything
fits together in math.
So I wrote that 3 there, so I
can erase all of this stuff.
Let me erase it.
I shouldn't have
erased the SOHCAHTOA.
Actually, we should have
that memorized by now.
SOHCAHTOA.
All right, so let's figure out
what this orange side is here.
And if you think about it, we
could do it a bunch of ways.
We could say, well, this is
the adjacent side, right?
Because we know the opposite
and we know the hypotenuse.
So we could either use-- we
know the opposite, so we could
say what trig function uses the
opposite and the adjacent?
Well, that's tangent
function, right?
So we could say tangent
of 0.36-- let's call
this side A, right?
A for adjacent.
Tangent of 0.36 is equal
to the opposite, 3, over
the adjacent, over A.
Is there another trigonometry
way we could think about this?
Well, we also know
the hypotenuse.
What trig function uses the
hypotenuse and the adjacent?
Well, if you remember,
SOH CAH TOA.
CAH, cosine is adjacent
over hypotenuse.
So we could say cosine of
0.36 is equal to adjacent
over square root of 73.
And I'll just write SOHCAHTOA
here, just so you can
confirm what I'm doing.
The TOA says the tangent is
equal to the opposite, 3, over
the adjacent, and CAH tells us
the cosine is equal to the
adjacent over the hypotenuse.
So we could solve
either one of these.
If we use the second formula,
we would get the adjacent side
is equal to the square root of
73 times the cosine of 0.36,
and then if you use your
calculator in radian mode, or
I'll just tell you, that cosine
of 0.36 radians is equal to 8
square roots of 73 over 73.
And you can confirm that by
getting a decimal number and
then-- making sure once again
your calculator is not in
degree mode, but
in radian mode.
I think that's actually the
default mode in a lot of
calculators-- and
solving for this.
But once again, the 73, this
square root of 73 times this
square root of 73, is equal to
73, and then divided by 73.
These all cancel out.
How convenient, huh?
And you get 8.
So the adjacent side
is equal to 8.
And so if we'd solved for A
here using the tangent
function, we should've also
gotten the adjacent
side is equal to 8.
And just to show you that
everything works out from other
concepts, let me show you this
using the Pythagorean theorem.
So 8 squared plus 3
squared should equal
the hypotenuse squared.
The square root of 73 squared.
Well, 8 squared is 64 plus 9
should equal-- what's the
square root of 73 squared?
Right, it's 73.
And, of course,
64 plus 9 is 73.
And sure enough, that
equals 73, so it works.
Isn't that interesting how math
just kind of fits together?
I think at this point you're
ready to try the modules, the
Trigonometry II modules, and I
guess let me know if you
have any problems, or if you
want to see more videos.
Have fun!